[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález el 30 de
abril del 2001 denis tito un millonario
estadounidense llegó a la estación
espacial internacional en una nave
espacial rusa soyuz que fue lanzada
desde el cosmódromo de baikonur en las
estepas de kazajistán en asia central 20
millones de dólares permitieron hacerle
ese sueño realidad en el marco del
inicio de la era del turismo espacial
pues vamos a ver entonces los casos
recientes porque 20 años después han
tenido que transcurrir y solamente un
selecto grupo de siete millonarios han
podido hacer algo similar en dos décadas
la industria turística espacial ha
avanzado enormemente empresas como space
ex blue origin y blue y virgin galactic
ven en este tipo de turismo un enorme
potencial como empresa un capítulo en la
historia comenzó nuevamente el pasado 11
de julio cuando ser bridge art richard
branson dueño de virgin galactic viajó
en un viaje de prueba junto a dos
pilotos ya cuatro empleados de la
compañía en un viaje
orbital unos días después el pasado 20
de julio de besòs dueño de la compañía
blue origin realizó también un viaje
suborbital en el que viajó con su
hermano marc oliver y james un ciudadano
estadounidense de 18 años y la
astronauta wally funk ambos lanzamientos
tuvieron un amplio cubrimiento mediático
generaron interés por parte de la
comunidad internacional y todo esto pues
en medio de la crisis de la pandemia de
kobe 19 esto nos sirvió para distraernos
pero también dejó muchas preguntas y eso
nos lleva entonces a nuestro tema de
análisis y debate de hoy estamos ante el
inicio oficial de la carrera por el
desarrollo de la industria del turismo
espacial para conversar sobre este tema
están con nosotros pablo de leonel es
profesor director del departamento de
estudios espaciales de la universidad de
dakota del norte también es investigador
externo de la nasa que es la agencia
espacial de eeuu él se encuentra en la
ciudad de grand forks en el estado de
dakota del norte en eeuu y también está
con nosotros césar fuentes astrónomos de
la universidad de chile- él se encuentra
en la ciudad de santiago
chilena en el extremo sur de nuestro
continente ustedes también nuestros
televidentes son parte de esta
conversación a través de las redes
sociales ustedes pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y preguntas las pueden
encontrar allí en nuestras cuentas de
facebook y también en twitter pueden
encontrar allí más información sobre
este tema estamos como arroba france24
guión bajo e s y también como arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
pueden dejar todos los comentarios con
el numeral el debate efe 24 también hay
una encuesta en línea en este momento y
la pregunta que se les está haciendo si
ustedes ingresan allí es esta de acuerdo
con la apuesta de los viajes comerciales
al espacio esperamos todas sus
respuestas y comentarios y opiniones
sobre este tema pues vamos a comenzar
entonces hablando con nuestros invitados
de la noche de hoy de nuestro programa
vamos a conversar con el pablo de león
preguntándole pablo es un hecho para
usted que comenzó el turismo espacial
ahora así como dicen en forma
bueno de alguna manera si claramente
como usted lo comentaba antes ya hace
unos cuantos años de distrito se había
convertido en el primer turista espacial
en hacer un vuelo orbital que desde ya
es mucho más grande y más complejo que
el vuelo este que vimos
justamente hace unos días que son
simplemente vuelos suborbitales son
vuelos de apenas unos minutos contra un
vuelo orbital que puede ser de semanas o
meses pero sí indudablemente estos son
proyectos que ya se han estado haciendo
desde hace una cantidad de años por
ejemplo
bersin galactic creo que había sido
fundada en el año 2004 y el caso de
blowing fue fundada en el año 2000 o
o sea que hace ya mucho tiempo que esta
gente está trabajando en este tipo de
proyectos intentando que estas naves
espaciales sean seguras y justamente se
puedan adaptar a el turismo espacial a
la utilización por parte de personas que
no califican como astronautas
profesionales y que no han tenido que
pasar por el nivel de entrenamiento que
requiere un astronauta profesional pero
indudablemente estamos
llegando a esta nueva etapa y césar
fuentes en la ciudad de santiago en
chile cuál es su opinión ya estamos
entonces ante el comienzo oficial o
formal del turismo espacial o si
efectivamente esto ya llevar todo tiempo
y partió con ésta
lo cierto apuesta de la de la agencia
rusa de financiar parte de sus
operaciones pagando estos tickets para
ir a la estación espacial en algo que
como va lo mencionado es bastante más
complejo de lo que hemos visto en la
última semana
y después de que eso para aparecen estas
otras empresas que aprovechando esta
inversión de riesgo que hacen asa para
cosas más grandes como ir a la luna a
pensar en ir a marte en algún futuro
tienen la capacidad para usando esa
inversión poder desarrollar estas otras
como empresas paralelas o negocios
paralelos de los cuales el más rápido de
poder de entregar algún beneficio es
todo el turismo espacial que requiere
mucho de novedad y requiere mucho de lo
que hemos visto de marketing
pablo este sistema de trabajo en
conjunto entre las agencias espaciales y
la empresa privada puede ser entonces el
punto de partida para recuperar esa
industria espacial esa carrera espacial
que tenía en eeuu y en su momento la
unión soviética posteriormente rusia que
estaba bastante diezmada del lado de los
rusos después de la caída de la urss
puesto había problemas presupuestales
había muchos problemas a nivel
tecnológico y de seguridad que
garantizarán la óptima operación de las
naves espaciales y también problemas
logísticos porque muchos de los centros
espaciales o los cosmódromo y bases
militares dedicadas a esto quedaron
fuera de las fronteras rusas el
cosmódromo de baikonur están kasajistán
y pagan 50 millones de dólares por
alquilar esta ciudad 50 millones al año
lo mismo pasaba en eeuu el programa
espacial también venía en desaceleración
los transbordadores espaciales muy
costosos de operar tuvieron que ser
puestos fuera de operación también por
los problemas técnicos que estaban
empezando a presentar esto entonces
marca un nuevo inicio no solamente como
turismo espacial sino también en la era
espacial de la historia de la humanidad
como lo vio usted bueno yo creo que el
modelo que existió durante la guerra
fría en el momento de la era espacial de
la llegada a la luna y como parte del
programa apolo es un modelo que no se
puede replicar en ese momento estaba por
un lado la unión soviética
y de alguna manera era una especie de
tensión constante entre estos dos países
para ver quién sé quién lograba y
cosechaba en determinados este récords o
no esto de alguna manera termina primero
con la llegada a la luna como parte del
programa apolo y finalmente con la caída
del muro de berlín y la desintegración
de la unión soviética yo creo que lo que
está pasando ahora es otra cosa pero sin
duda hay un renacimiento de las
actividades espaciales yo lo veo aquí en
eeuu el entusiasmo no ya de los
especialistas de la gente que estamos
trabajando en el programa espacial pero
sí no
el público de la opinión pública uno
cuando va a ver los lanzamientos veces
entusiasmo miles y miles de personas que
se reúnen para ver estos lanzamientos y
para de alguna manera sentirse
partícipes de esto que era algo parecido
a lo que ocurría en la época del apolo
pero ya digamos sin un rival y tan claro
como era el caso de la unión soviética
hoy día y otros actores están las
empresas privadas desde ya y también
tenemos el caso de china por ejemplo que
es un competidor serio en la temática
espacial pero de una manera muy
diferente a como ocurría en la época de
la guerra fría creo que es no se puede
comparar pero sí existe el mismo nivel o
un nivel parecido de entusiasmo en la
opinión pública y creo que ello es muy
importante también se está de usted como
astrónomo allí en la ciudad de santiago
como vivió estos momentos estos dos
recientes viajes suborbitales realizados
por estos dos empresarios y millonarios
como recibieron usted y sus colegas este
tipo de aventuras digámoslo así y la
venta de elementos como
de distancia yo creo que esto demuestra
un poco y haciéndome tomando un poco lo
que sea pablo
esto yo creo que también es difícil de
replicar esto de la guerra fría y esta
carrera espacial más antigua comparado a
esta nueva de comillas carrera espacial
con respecto a la forma de organizarse
de que ir por estos problemas difíciles
anteriormente en estas empresas si no
pudieran tirar a la nasa alguna empresa
y llevarlos a roscósmos como una empresa
muy vertical muy gigante con grupos que
trabajan de paso a paso y comparado con
esto que de nuevo no es raro que la
gente o parte importante los que están
involucrados en esta nueva carrera
espacial vengan del mundo del software
donde la forma de trabajar y avanzar
tiene el harto de mucha prueba y error
de avanzar muy rápido con equipos
pequeños y es un poco lo que estamos
viendo en estas
esta parte del proceso que es de los más
costosos de ir al espacio que tiene que
ver con los lanzamientos entonces esa
nueva forma de trabajar también junto
con quien ha se haya decidido entregar
parte de ese problema a privados yo creo
que hay una buena sinergia y en lo que
son buenos los privados y en particular
esta forma de trabajar más común del
mundo del software comer ciudad que con
esta inversión que hace del estado que
permite que se desarrollen otros
negocios como este y como otros que van
a ser bastante más importantes para
todos nosotros como por ejemplo es
actualmente poder hacer estos modelos
orbital es más difícil de lo que hemos
visto
en los cuales uno puede realmente estar
entre dos puntos de la tierra en
principio en menos de 45 minutos eso sí
podría ser cambiarnos a nosotros la
perspectiva de las cosas que son
factibles de hacer acá en la tierra y
una consecuencia más útil de esta
carrera espacial
a ver quiero preguntarle a los dos como
ven esto como industria como potencial
de negocio que pueda tener el turismo
espacial ha sido dos décadas de
desarrollo desde ese primer viaje de
titto a la estación espacial
internacional hasta lo que hemos visto
en los últimos días de acuerdo a lo que
dicen los estudios es un mercado
potencial de más de 10 mil millones de
dólares en desarrollar este turismo
espacial pero sigue siendo muy
restringido solamente los millonarios
las personas más acaudaladas van a poder
acceder a esos tiquetes para viajes de
unos cuantos minutos como lo vio usted
de pablos desde la perspectiva como
negocio esto tiene potencial siendo tan
costoso yo creo que es muy temprano para
poder determinar si va a terminar siendo
un buen negocio no creo que estas
empresas tanto blue origin como virgin
galactic y han invertido cientos de
cientos y cientos de millones de dólares
para llegar a este punto y desde ya si
estamos hablando que un pasaje en ticket
va a costar entre 250 y 300 mil dólares
van a necesitar vender unos cuantos para
poder recuperar la inversión que
hicieron a lo largo de estos casi 20
años entonces ahí hay que ver cuál va a
ser el interés de la gente
de poder gastarse lo que cuesta más o
menos una casa media en los eeuu en diez
o quince minutos o veinte minutos de un
vuelo espacial no eso de alguna manera
global no va a terminar determinando el
mercado creo que también tiene una
cantidad de otras aplicaciones que son
aplicaciones científicas porque a ver
por ejemplo universidades o institutos
de investigación de repente pueden
enviar un investigador a hacer
experiencias o pueden enviar
experimentos a este tipo de este tipo de
vuelos para hacer experiencias con
microgravedad y demás bueno cuál creo
que tiene una utilidad que va más allá
de los fugas de la experiencia del
astronauta o turista espacial de 10
minutos y que tiene otras aplicaciones y
además un poco como comentaba césar esto
va a traer una serie de innovaciones de
en diferentes planos que nos van a
permitir avanzar todavía más la
tecnología yo personalmente lo veo como
algo como algo positivo y por otro lado
es el fin del monopolio de los gobiernos
como únicos elementos para lanzar
personas al espacio ya había ocurrido
con spacex hace unos meses cuando
hicieron las primeras misiones a la
estación espacial internacional con
astronautas y ahora se ve en un plano un
poco este más específicamente turístico
como lo podemos ver con esta con estas
naves y definitivamente terminó con el
monopolio de los rusos de tener la
puerta al espacio hasta hace unos años
la única forma de llegar a la estación
espacial internacional o al espacio en
sí mismo era saliendo desde baikonur en
kazajistán en una nave sayús y ahora
pues hay múltiples opciones de a usted
lo decía los chinos también han dado
unos pasos importantes en el desarrollo
de su programa espacial y han entrenado
ya a muchas tripulaciones y están
desarrollando sus propias naves césar su
opinión sobre este tema del desarrollo
del potencial que pueda tener como
industria y también como una forma de
desarrollar otro tipo de tecnologías y
de estudios
y yo lo veo positivo en él en términos
de lo que es desarrollo tecnología
evidentemente estos privados le han
enseñado cosas a la nasa para disminuir
los costos de estos lanzamientos
rentablemente esto lo hemos visto en
otras tecnologías antes de que los
estados invierten para resolver
problemas complejos luego llegan los
privados hacen lo que hacen los privados
quieres desarrollar formas de vender
esto democratizar lo que nuestro el
mundo significa más que utilizarlo
transformarlo en compradores en el fondo
y lamentablemente la regulación que es
más fácil cuando es entre gobiernos es
más difícil cuando entran los privados y
la regulación siempre viene unos varios
pasos atrás
por ejemplo yo que vengo del mundo de la
astronomía nosotros estamos viendo el
problema no de el primer negocio que yo
a bulgari jeans y virgin galactic que
escribimos parcial sino que el primer
negocio que vi o spacex de la que no la
estamos nombrando pero desde la más
exitosa
bajar estos costes de hacer cosas bien
impresionantes para enviar cosas al
espacio
qué es esto de starling quieres mandar
una tremenda cantidad de satélites
pequeños para cualquier cosa y una de
esas cosas que se les ocurrió es dar
internet a zonas rurales en que uno no
tiene acceso a cable lo cual es muy
loable y muy necesario pero para poder
hacer eso en lugares que están cerca el
ecuador como colombia no necesito la
tremenda cantidad de estos satélites en
general están en órbitas polares del
polo norte al polo sur que como cuando
uno corta una naranja se acumulan esas
líneas cerca de los polos entonces en el
caso de chile vamos a poder tener ese
servicio antes porque uno necesita menos
de estos satélites en órbita sin embargo
eso significa que la contaminación que
viene asociada con estas nuevas
tecnologías nos van a afectar ante iban
a libia está produciendo problemas para
la imagen astronómica ya vamos a hablar
del tema ambiental también y de lo que
puede ser en términos de beneficios para
la humanidad pero le pregunto sedes al
chico con usted hago la ronda a la
inversa entonces usted es muy difícil la
posible democratización del espacio
claramente podemos coincidir en que un
espacio muy bien administrado puede ser
muy beneficioso para todos pero cree
usted que puede ser muy difícil llegar a
esa democratización césar yo creo que de
repente uno no quiere democratizar el
espacio yo pienso lo siguiente la
antártica da una tremenda cantidad de
posibilidades y uno podría pensar en
democratizar la tarta porque cada país
tuviera un pedazo y lo explotará sin
embargo los países reconocieron que era
bueno para todo el mundo
dejarlo medio virgen preocuparse de no
tocar lo tanto ese modelo que yo creo
que es muy útil para el espacio no no
existe para el espacio en el espacio es
un tipo si aquí el que llega primero se
lo lleva y lamentablemente eso abre la
puerta para
desarrollo no abuso sino que desarrolle
lo más rápido ser el primero el que
llega primero esta es la punta del cerro
para ver más allá que otras
posibilidades agentes y en las cuales
las preocupaciones medioambientales lo
que afecta al resto que es más difícil
de ver y este discurso es importante
cuando estamos viendo problemas con el
clima en todas partes hay una lección
ahí que no estamos aprendiendo
definitivamente
también es parte de la humanidad siempre
querer más ya llegamos a la tirada la
luna queremos llegar a marte queremos
instaurar colonias fuera de nuestro
planeta y siempre hemos querido llegar
más allá y tal vez eso es lo que ha
hecho que esta industria siga
evolucionando y no se detenga y también
bueno la curiosidad humana por saber que
hay más allá de las fronteras de nuestro
planeta
-pablo su opinión sobre este tema de la
democratización que es uno de los
grandes debates a nivel internacional de
quién es el espacio quiénes van a poder
acceder a él quiénes pueden acceder a
este tipo de viajes
y si esto es abierto para todos
si yo no me llevo muy bien con la
expresión democratización del espacio
porque en un planeta donde todavía no
todo el mundo tiene acceso al agua
potable no todo el mundo tiene acceso a
alimentos este etcétera etcétera estamos
hablando de digamos darle la posibilidad
todo el mundo que pueda llegar al
espacio utilizar el espacio es un poco
complejo por otro lado si veo que la
vida humana en nuestro planeta si
nosotros no buscamos recursos más allá
de él tiene los días contados ya hay una
cantidad de minerales que están
empezando a escasear en la tierra
y hay infinitas cantidades de los mismos
en los cinturones de asteroides y
tenemos elementos en la luna y en marte
que eventualmente servirán en un futuro
desde ella para poder continuar nuestra
evolución y nuestro camino aquí en el
planeta tierra yo creo que hemos llegado
al punto donde la utilización de
recursos espaciales es fundamental
quienes van a ser los países que tengan
acceso a ello
evidentemente en más allá de que hay un
tratado que dice que el espacio y los
cuerpos celestes son patrimonio común de
la humanidad claramente las naciones que
tengan presencia en el espacio van a
tener acceso a estos recursos y el resto
se verá no por ello yo creo que es muy
importante que las naciones tengan
tengan capacidad espacial no quizás en
función de sus capacidades pero tengan
una cierta capacidad espacial y que de
alguna manera puedan colaborar y puedan
tener una presencia concreta en lo que
va a venir en el siglo 21 y más allá que
va a ser la dependencia del planeta
tierra de los recursos extraterrestres
eso es algo que hoy hoy día puede sonar
de ciencia ficción pero es algo que en
un punto determinado va a ser
absolutamente imprescindible estoy
hablando de energía eléctrica estoy
hablando de minerales y de otros
recursos que vamos a necesitar aquí en
la tierra para poder seguir y seguir
evolucionando debido a la escasez de
estos elementos en nuestro planeta
pablo y eso me lleva a pensar en
términos legales por ejemplo si una
tripulación de uno de estos viajes de
turismo pensando en unos años más
adelante cuando ya esté mucho más
desarrollado todo este tema descubren
algo que es vital para el planeta tierra
un mineral algún componente que sé yo
vida más allá de lo que tenemos en
nuestra concepción ese tipo de hallazgos
para quien queda cuando hay una empresa
privada de por medio que claramente
necesita beneficios y un estado que
necesita pues también sacar un poco de
orgullo y de pecho por lograr este tipo
de desarrollos importantes para la
humanidad cómo queda eso ahí
bueno es interesante que comenté eso
santiago porque usted sabe que a pesar
que existen tratados internacionales
donde las naciones de alguna manera o
algunas naciones se han puesto de
acuerdo en la distribución de los
recursos y en la no apropiación del
espacio y sus recursos por otro lado
hace unos años creo que fue en el 2014 o
2015 los eeuu en ese momento estaba el
presidente obama sacaron una ley en la
cual cualquier empresa o cualquier
individuo de los eeuu que quisiera
utilizar los recursos de un asteroide o
de otro planeta para su empresa y vender
esos recursos no puede que hay de alguna
manera una como decirle una diferencia
entre los tratados internacionales y lo
que esta ley en particular u otros otras
naciones creo que fue el existente y
algunos otros lugares que también
sacaron leyes parecidas diciendo si las
empresas de nuestro país si los
individuos en nuestro país quieren
utilizar los recursos
de un asteroide o de otro planeta para
su beneficio lo van a poder hacer
césar pasó a preguntarle por el
secretismo que hay detrás de los
programas espaciales todo lo que sabe la
nasa todo lo que sabe roscósmos que no
sabe la humanidad todos los hallazgos
que ellos han hecho todos los
desarrollos tecnológicos que tuvieron
que implementar para poder llegar a
donde está en el día de hoy que tanto
están dispuestos los gobiernos de eeuu
de rusia y de china dejar ver a simples
turistas que puedan ir en estos viajes
sobre los programas espaciales porque
supongamos que van a llegar algunos
turistas a la estación espacial
internacional como está previsto para
los próximos meses no van a llegar a un
hotel cinco estrellas como cualquier
turista normal van a llegar a una
estación espacial que es un centro
científico es como llegar a una base
militar restringida de cualquiera de
estos países
ahí no entran muchos intereses también
en juego que se pueda filtrar
información que haya mal uso de
información indispensable fundamental y
secreta que haya allí reservada como lo
ve usted
y me cuesta imaginar algo que sea
secreto que está ahí en la estación
espacial cuando los astronautas de
repente se seguirán se toma fotos en la
estación espacial que tampoco es tan tan
grande
pero cierto que hay bastantes secretos
que tienen que ver más que nada con la
protección de esta tremenda inversión
que significa tener algo en órbita y la
investigación que hay en torno a eso que
tiene mucho que ver con mantener gente
en órbita después de que rusia pierde
entre comillas la carrera espacial
siguen con algo que tiene mucho sentido
quiere mantener la presencia del humano
en la órbita y eeuu llegó a la luna
después con esto de los chats los que
cayeron en desgracia en algún momento
por los locales y ahora los estamos
estando de menos por suerte el haul lo
pudieron recuperar ahora porque sin chat
no existe la capacidad la tierra para ir
y reparar en algo que va a tomar más d
de un par de horas el telescopio para
sal por ejemplo
y los secretos industriales tienen que
ver con lo difícil que sea y la
tecnología para enviar estas naves al
espacio y poder hacer que aterricen de
nuevamente tiene que ver con ese tipo de
tecnologías no con un pedazo de hardware
que sea fácil de copiar por ejemplo
pero por supuesto que es todos los
gobiernos y las empresas son muy
cuidadosas del desarrollo que cada vez
tiene más que ver con ideas que con
cosas
y en esto en el desarrollo espacial dado
que estamos como partiendo lo bueno de
esto que hay empresas pequeñas es que
hay más espacio para naciones pequeñas
como en latinoamérica como nuestras
naciones representadas para aportar e
imaginar nuevas formas de por ejemplo
mirar asteroides que esto como hacer una
casa en el papel lo ponemos tres pisos
le ponemos 10 da lo mismo
pablo y su opinión sobre el secretismo
de estos programas espaciales y la
información que pueda revelarse estando
allí en un viaje turístico si estoy de
acuerdo en realidad hoy por hoy las
agencias espaciales en muy poco lo que
pueden llegar a ocultar la nasa es una
agencia civil que salvo que sean vuelos
específicamente militares por esta nueva
mente creada space space force digamos
que en el futuro posiblemente van a van
a también enviar sus propios astronautas
al espacio pero la nasa y las agencias
espaciales que pueden ser roscósmos la
agencia espacial europea etcétera no
pueden en realidad mantener secretos
demasiado importantes más allá del tema
justamente como lo que estaba comentando
césar de de determinadas ideas o
determinados inventos de hecho la nasa
hoy día tiene una restricción para
emplear ciudadanos chinos o
instituciones chinas justamente por este
tema de las patentes o las ideas y los
sistemas no y aquí está el tema de la
reutilización qué es
es importante y es de alguna manera lo
que cambia el juego imagínese usted
cuánto costaría un ticket de avión
comercial si hubiera que romper el avión
después de un vuelo y eso es lo que
vinimos haciendo desde el principio de
la carrera espacial hasta ahora está
reutilización de los vehículos
espaciales es la que va a posibilitar el
acceso al espacio con costes muy muy
reducidos y dar la nueva el nuevo nuevo
paso en la exploración espacial
-pablo el sigo con usted y ya que usted
habla de los precios ha sido una de las
grandes críticas a nivel internacional
los astronómicos precios que han tenido
que pagar este grupo de millonarios para
poder realizar estos viajes muchos lo
ven como una posibilidad de garantizar
que muchas personas del común puedan
realizar estos viajes pero es que vemos
que el 82 por ciento de la humanidad no
ha viajado ni siquiera en avión va a
poder acceder a pagar estos precios pues
es un poco impensable no
vamos sin duda sin duda tengamos en
cuenta que cuando comenzó la aviación
comercial el precio de un ticket para
volar de un lugar al otro era
extremadamente caro y a lo largo del
tiempo y el perfeccionamiento de los
aviones y de las técnicas de aviación
aerocomercial se han reducido por
supuesto y eso me retrotrae a la
pregunta suya del tema de la
democratización del espacio va a tener
todo el mundo la posibilidad ser un
vuelo espacial seguramente no pero yo a
veces pienso no solamente en el en el
vuelo del turista espacial sino en toda
esa tecnología todas esas cosas que van
a venir aparejadas gracias a este
desarrollo que va a tener lugar en el
turismo espacial pasó lo mismo durante
el programa polo y seguirá pasando en
otros proyectos también que se que se
realizaron hay beneficios tangibles que
mejoran la vida de la gente aquí en la
tierra más allá de que solamente un
puñado de personas puedan volar 10
minutos al espacio esto apalanca
muchísimas otras cosas ya ustedes lo han
dicho
aquí hacer que una diferencia para los
televidentes sobre el tipo de viajes que
han realizado a lo largo de estos años
los turistas espaciales hay viajes
orbitales y suborbitales cuál es la
diferencia entre ellos rápidamente
porque ya hemos llegando al final por
favor
estamos pegados a la tierra por la
gravedad que tenemos a esta distancia al
centro de la tierra a esta distancia
para poder escapar de la gravedad de la
tierra uno necesita más energía cinética
y esa energía la velocidad si uno a
cualquier cosa se le entrega unos 11,4
11 12 kilómetros por segundo o sea 5
segundos de alguna estarían 150 pero en
palabras simples esa porque está muy
técnico y esto es para la gente del
común que quiere 11 quiero me contarse
una nave y volar orbital o support vital
que es eso sí olvidar es que tú estás
prácticamente a la misma distancia y te
mantienes separado de la tierra no
porque estás pisando la tierra sino
porque la velocidad hace que tus fuerzas
entre juegue la que uno siente cuando
uno dobla esa fuerza equipara a la
fuerza a gravedad de toda la tierra
para eso necesitas tener una velocidad
que hace que des una oferta a la tierra
cada 90 minutos
esos orbitales su orbital es cualquier
cosa como subir y bajar que no te
alcanza para darte una vuelta completa
listo que haya explicado para nuestros
televidentes para el cierre pablo la
basura espacial preocupa el tema
ambiental todas las basuras y la huella
ambiental que puede dejar este tipo de
viajes en la atmósfera
bueno el tema de los viajes de los
cohetes en sí no mucho por ejemplo el
cohete de blue origin en realidad
utiliza como combustible hidrógeno y
oxígeno hidrógeno oxígeno cuando
nosotros lo mezclamos lo único que
producimos es agua con lo cual va a
dejar un poco de vapor de agua en la
atmósfera terrestre no va haber
demasiados problemas el problema así
real es en la basura espacial la
cantidad de pequeños satélites que
quedan en órbita baja que eventualmente
van a ir quemándose cayendo en las capas
superiores de la atmósfera y van a caer
a tierra si está el problema como lo que
me comentaba césar antes del tema de
starling por ejemplo que los satélites
están generando disrupciones en la
observación astronómica
y existe la posibilidad de que un objeto
de basura espacial golpea una de estas
naves espaciales una estación espacial
internacional etcétera bueno se estima
que cada uno de estos vuelos de virgin
galactic is the blue origin emite entre
60 y 90 toneladas de dióxido de carbono
respectivamente es decir unas 8 ó 15
toneladas por cada uno de los pasos
claro hay que decir que solamente 100
cohetes de estos son lanzados al año
desde los diferentes puntos de partida
hacia el espacio es muy distinto a la
industria aeronáutica que tienen cerca
de 100 mil aviones volando diariamente
que es una de las industrias que más
contamina a nivel ambiental pablo de
león y césar fuentes muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate france24 haber compartido con
nosotros su conocimiento sobre esta
industria su conocimiento sobre el
espacio y sus perspectivas sobre cómo
reciben ustedes el desarrollo de esta
posible industria turística espacial y
todo lo que esto puede traer para la
humanidad en sí muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales les recuerdo hay
una encuesta en línea pueden seguir
dejando allí sus respuestas participen
dejen sus comentarios sigan con la
programación de france 24
[Música]